[Applause]
there are a few places in England more
loyal to the Tories and yet in this
corner of Devon it's time to show Boris
the door
a lib Dem takeover
do you think people are really voting
for you or is this just a vote against
the Tories well there's certainly a very
positive vote for Richard Ford and the
liberal Democrats here in Tifton Honiton
but I I thank you I agree there were
some people for whom what they want to
do was send a message to conservative
MPS it's time Boris Johnson should go
and I agree with them
it is the third time recently that the
lib Dems have overturned a five-figure
majority in seats like this Ed Davey
says they are coming for the
conservatives seat by seat and you don't
have to look far to find Tory MPS
nervously watching on and wondering if
their majorities will hold in a general
election
I'm okay I I feel that I've paid the
price so Neil Parish the Tory MP here
for 12 years resigned after watching
porn in the comments at the last
election he won 60 of the vote do you
feel responsible for what happened I had
made a very foolish and and bad mistake
but I did The Honorable thing and left
and I think you know I thought that
would sort of help the party but I think
because in in on reflection it probably
hasn't because I think a lot of people
in the constituency said we like meal
Parish we thought he was very foolish
um but he did The Honorable thing what
about the Prime Minister and I think
that was the trouble he can't just keep
living in a parallel universe and there
has to be reality foreign
and the reality is this leave-leaning
rural Heartland has witnessed one of the
worst by-election defeats since the
Second World War I think the people have
had their say really haven't they to be
honest and
yeah nobody's got any confidence anymore
it was a protest vote I imagine the
general election being the area of Tears
it would revert back
what comes up again and again here are
agricultural issues fuel costs labor
votes will loaned their share collapsed
but in the end it was a PM that lost the
public what lib Dem policies attracted
you to vote for them they're just a
change none in particular so it wasn't
really about politics politics it was
about again personality as much as
anything else did you bet in the
by-election Oh indeed who did you vote
for I voted conservative as I would
always nearly always do not tempted by
the lib dams not in the least no
but after years of wilderness the lib
Dems are seizing by elections are rarely
good for the government they shouldn't
be this bad Ali Fortescue Sky News
Tiverton in Devon